krebs wird einfach weggesprengt kind
nach zwei stunden wieder belebt und
killer krokodil gefunden was diese woche
in der welt der wissenschaft passiert
ist jetzt in den krieg zum top five news
den krebs in die luft sprengen wie nun
in der fachzeitschrift journal of
physical chemistry bekannt gegeben wurde
hat ein forscherteam die wohl coolste
möglichkeit gefunden und krebs zu
bekämpfen
man strengt ihn einfach aus dem körper
kleine sogenannte baki bombs bestehen
aus 60 einzelnen kohlenstoffatomen die
in einer bestimmten formation angeordnet
sind wenn diese erhitzt werden reagieren
die kohlenstoff atome mit sauerstoff die
starke verbindung der kohlenstoff atome
untereinander bricht und setzt dabei
eine relativ große menge energie frei
die forscher sagen man könnte diese nano
explosion in zukunft nutzen um extrem
präzise krebszellen zu zerstören oder
dabei umliegende gesunde zellen zu
beschädigen
mit einer spritze könnte man die mini
kohlenstoff bomben in das krebsgewebe
einführen und per uv lampe dann
detonieren lassen kind nach zwei stunden
wieder belebt ein tragischer unfall
ereignete sich letzten mittwoch als er
nicht einmal zwei jahre altes kind in
einem fluss in pennsylvania viel
ungefähr 30 minuten lang war das kind in
ein grad kaltem wasser bis ein nachbar
den jungen schließlich reglos aufwand er
hatte keinen puls und atmete nicht mehr
die rettungskräfte die extrem schnell am
unfallort eintrafen begannen sofort mit
den wiederbelebungsmaßnahmen
der helikopter wurde der junge dann in
ein nahe gelegenes krankenhaus geflogen
bei 25 grad körpertemperatur und nach 20
minuten herz lungen wiederbelebung wurde
dann endlich ein puls festgestellt
unglaublicher weise konnten die ärzte im
wechsel die anstrengende wiederbelebung
über eine stunde und 40 minuten aufrecht
erhalten also die haben quasi als erz
lungen maschine gearbeitet
der junge konnte ohne erkennbaren
neurologische gehirnschäden fünf tage
später wieder mit seinen eltern nach
hause kommen aber wie ist das möglich
größtenteils aus zwei gründen die
wassertemperatur hat seine herz
geschwindigkeit sehr sehr schnell auf
ein minimales level herabgesenkt das
wiederum senkt den sauerstoffverbrauch
des körpers so dass das gehirn lange
genug mit ausreichend sauerstoff
versorgt werden konnte
interessanterweise ist dieser effekt bei
kindern wesentlich stärker als bei
erwachsenen
außerdem sorgt eine unterkühlung dafür
dass das gehirn und hin bis zu 50
weniger sauerstoff in anspruch nimmt
sein alter und die temperatur haben dem
jungen aus pennsylvania also das leben
gerettet und ich kann euch nur den tipp
geben und das ist das was wir auch so
etwas lernen wenn ihr jemand findet
dessen herz still gestanden ist dann
sofort mit herzdruckmassage und beatmung
beginnen und das könnt ihr wirklich ganz
ganz lange machen das ist wahnsinnig
anstrengend also holt euch jemand dazu
aber auf diese weise kann man über
minuten oder wie das in dem fall haben
über mehr als eine stunde das leben
erhalten weil man selber als herz lungen
maschine funktioniert also man kann
jemand der war quasi am rand des todes
schwebt dem kann man ganz ganz lange am
leben erhalten
und das wäre eine tolle möglichkeit um
mehr menschen das leben zu retten
riesiges pazifik reservat angekündigt
großbritannien hat ein riesiges gebiet
im südpazifik als reservat ausgerufen
und will es in zukunft dementsprechend
beschützen
mehr als 800.000 quadratkilometer meer
rund um die pid köln inseln sollen
dadurch von fischern geschützt werden
denn in den korallenriffen des gebietes
gibt es über 1200 verschiedene
fischarten
das gebiet wird in zukunft das weltweit
größte zusammenhängende fisch reservat
der welt obwohl das im september letzten
jahres eröffnete gebiet der vereinigten
staaten im zentralpazifik mit 1,2
millionen quadratkilometern größer ist
es besteht allerdings aus sieben kleinen
reservaten millionen neuer sterne
entstanden eine zwerggalaxie ganz in
unserer nähe produziert anscheinend
sterne in unglaublicher menge und
geschwindigkeit besonders für die größe
der galaxie ist das sehr ungewöhnlich
teilweise würden hunderte von sternen
gleichzeitig entstehen
das forscherteam geht davon aus dass die
zwerggalaxien aus irgend einem grund so
funktioniert wie die ersten galaxien
nach dem urknall in dieser zeit unseres
universums haben galaxien viel mehr
sterne produziert als heutzutage die
entdeckung der galaxie könnte uns
deshalb weitere erkenntnisse über die
vergangenheit unseres universums bieten
und uns zum beispiel die frage
beantworten wie sie heutzutage weniger
neue sterne entstehen
die forscher möchten den nebel der nur
lichtjahre von uns entfernt es in
zukunft genauer beobachten
das krokodil das aufrecht ging
forscher haben in den usa die fossilien
eines offenbar über zwei meter siebzig
langen krokodils gefunden das aufrecht
gehen konnte vor über 230 millionen
jahren dürfte es laut meinung der
forscher mit diesem vorteil an der
spitze der nahrungskette gestanden haben
abgesehen vom klettern auf einen baum
gäbe es nichts was einen vor diesem
raubtier hätte bewahren können
es war groß stark und auf den
hinterbeinen wohl auch sehr schnell
kurze sprints um die beute dann mit den
messerscharfen zähnen einzufangen
sollten kein problem für das ungeheuer
gewesen sein auch unsere heutigen
krokodile können manchmal auf ihren
hinterbeinen laufen
das allerdings nur ein paar schnelle
schritte um die distanz zu ihrer beute
zu überwinden um etwas ähnlich
ungeheures geht es im buch der schwarm
von frank schätzing super spannend und
trotzdem auch wissenschaftlich extrem
interessant ich hab's gelesen und human
und zeitsprung hieraus kölner
produktionsverfahren berechtigen kaufte
ich bin so gespannt auf den kinofilm
aber bis dahin als hörbuch unglaublich
wie ihr euch bei audible ein probe
account erstellt dann bekommt ihr das
hörbuch kostenlos als geschenk und wer
der schwarm schon kennt den könnte auch
das hörspiel interessieren alle links
dazu unten in der video beschreibung
eine weitere möglichkeit um den krebs zu
bekämpfen findet ihr in diesem video
krebs spontan gehalt dafür um klicken zu
quick step zum blog da kommt ihr
unternehmen allerdings zu den
angesprochenen themen findet ihr wie
immer unten in der video beschreibung
und was meint ihr was kann man tun oder
muss man tun wenn man jemand findet der
vielleicht tot am boden link liegt was
habt ihr im erste hilfe kurs gelernt und
was ist wichtig und könnte man
tatsächlich mehr leben dadurch retten
schreibt es unten in den kommentaren
bis dann bleibt dran